In the house.
We just got done doing the podcast.
We're so casual.
I'm wearing socks,
so he's got fucking flip flops on.
I got a cock hold my finger tips.
Give a shit crazy.
You were fucking hilarious today as well.
And if they wanna watch
your show birth to conquer.
It's on every Sunday night.
Oh,
travel channel at eight o'clock Bam.
And spell dispelled.
Bert Kreischer for the B.
A lot of words.
The letters,
right.
Brian should change that
to what k likes to fuck.
Yeah,
like Danny Kaye will
remind people of Nostalgia.
You're like an old school entertainer.
Be Bert,
Bert,
three times all it.
Well,
now that you said it,
someone's going to go grab it
30 minutes.
Give me 30 minutes.
Don't post this time.
30 minutes.
Bert,
Bert for permanent,
try to change it.
That's not a bad idea because
people probably can't spell crusher
twice.
Yeah,
the wrong.
The first time I tried it when I just
yesterday I had to go back and look at my
Twitter and get it right.
It'd be great if I was in Germany.
Why is that?
Because then everyone knows how to
spell cards should be a crutch for us.
You mean like Rogan?
Yeah.
Crushers.
A tricky one,
right?
I think birth prep work.
Could you get that Bert?
Bert.
Bert Twitter.
Yeah.
Prep.
Prep,
prep.
Do you really need all those letters?
It was Bert.
Bert.
If I just go Bubba,
Bubba,
bubba.
How about Burke?
Did you see Bert
never know.
Mass tweet.
First time to be taken
per toys taken right away.
I had the chance to buy Bert,
um,
the Burt website,
burt.com and I was like,
websites.
Who's gonna fucking use these?
What am I going to post up?
Shit on it.
I almost had Joe rogan.com
at one point in time.
Then this fucking real estate
guy got it out from under me.
The same thing I didn't think of,
well,
it was a website.
Then I can give a shit
about website available.
Is that take the bait so
people will know.
Find me.
Prepper bird on Twitter.
Oh No,
it's Holly Koon is the girl's name.
How about Bert?
X three x three that's ridiculous.
What if I got Burt Reynolds?
You can get burnt.
Raul's fuck yeah.
He spelled the same way.
Or is it B u r t though?
It's,
Oh,
it's B u r t but I'll be br drunk.
Bert.
Did you try to give birth
to conquer to it's too many.
What letters?
Travel.
Telegraph.
Burke conquers moves like two active of
and that still people are not going to
flaking on how to spell conqueror.
Conquer is hard to spell it.
I have to show and I fucking out CLN.
See Kong were you usually you are.
I have a CNS.
UNC.
See UNK conch were caucus.
Yeah.
This is our video blog.
We do this every week.
Now.
I know what the fuck's going on,
man.
This is full of multimedia.
Yeah,
man.
We're perfecting,
attacking on all fronts to try to try to
avoid the Hollywood machine for when I
make my,
my truck out of California again,
it's not Brian's kind.
Let me,
right Brian,
if it's Texas or maybe boulder or Denver.
Yeah,
boulder,
maybe Denver.
I don't think I want to go
anywhere like Oregon or anything.
San Diego,
how you want to
say hi to everyone?
Listen,
this is being recorded
so don't say the n word.
Okay.
Keep going.
I love you.
I'll talk to you later.
All right.
Greetings,
civilized gentlemen and ladies.
Throughout the land we break,
we drink wine like the
sophisticated we are,
we are multifaceted.
We have wine,
coconut water,
and yeah,
we don't fuck around.
We have a plethora of beverages here.
Kevin Pereira is here
from attack of the show
and just life.
I want,
don't want to define you,
but one thing that's all right.
Most people do.
Hey Man,
you talking about your factor guy.
Nice legs on the line,
legs
spread.
And you were telling us this,
this wine is,
uh,
it's,
it comes from some guy who was an
infomercial came apparently he made a
bazillion,
uh,
off of infomercials in the 90s.
Bought a bunch of land and they have it.
I love stories like that.
Like how,
how to ditch slow me.
How did Mr Slap Chop?
Really Matt?
Yeah,
that guy.
Yeah.
He fucked up with a hooker.
Prostitutes.
You the slap chop guy shot him.
Right.
Did she bite his tongue because he
was telling her and then he hit her.
She bit his tongue and he thinks that,
yeah.
Your timing in a hooker man,
woe to,
you know,
he's like a beat directory.
Direct studies,
the worst damn comedy movie or
something like that already.
Just did,
uh,
did the last movie with them and
I guess he's just a dirty fuck.
[inaudible]
you shouldn't in promoting the Shama then
he could have cleaned up the shame and
the crime afterwards.
Yeah.
That guy's probably rich
as fuck from that sham.
Wow.
Fun though.
Huh?
Fuck yeah.
Now I could fund movies.
He had Lindsay Lohan and
that was the last one.
I guess I just watched a ridiculous,
this commercial with Elisabeth Hasselbeck,
whatever.
What does it is a bit
hassled then had a really,
really conservative ones interview
and she's on a fucking app thing.
Stupid machine.
There's no way it fucking works.
And she's standing there ripped
and chisel looking sexy as fuck.
You know,
like with a little thing.
Total exposed APP.
Talking about this allows
me to keep in shape.
If you're like me and you don't have the
time to get to the gym or the view will
enjoy this view,
vaginal muscle,
it's a stupid product,
but I bet she's going to make $1 billion.
Every time I see another plastic
thing with belts or police or leavers,
I go,
I gotta come up with
the next one and I go,
there's no more ways to do a crunch.
And then some asshole comes up with the,
here's the device you strap on,
lay down,
and it works your core.
They always keep coming up.
There's one that's just a spring
with a stick and he'd go like that.
Have you seen that one?
Yeah.
It's like sticks between
your life looks so stupid,
like a shock absorber.
And he pushed down like my dad
believed in the weight belts.
That would shock you
like a little ad belts.
Right?
My Dad's big old gut,
so he went and got two of
the most powerful ones you
could get and he would put
them on you supposed to be like lose
your belly with Kay white jelly or
something like that so it doesn't
conduct right to the skin.
He wouldn't do that.
He's giant in Portuguese and angry.
So He'd wear two belts,
like sit there for like four hours and
just watch Jerry Springer and then he's
done.
He would have either played,
connect the dots on his belly,
but he was just shocking his gut
to some ways that didn't work.
It didn't work.
That doesn't work well.
Electrical muscle stimulation they
use in rehab so it has some sort of an
effect,
right,
but it's more grainy nine plastic belt
that you're getting at 4:00 AM is not
going to be the same of
stem you're getting from.
But if just chiropractors crank him up,
have the same effect at times,
make noises,
but 23 does that.
When he moves in bout
what?
I had a,
I don't know,
bad muscle pull.
My leg wants to put me on that shit.
Electrical muscular stimulation and
try to revive the area that was torn.
It's interesting to work.
Um,
I don't know,
you know,
everything heals up in time.
It's hard to say what
exactly made heal up.
But,
um,
they had,
they were selling them on,
on TV for bodybuilders,
but if that shit worked,
there'd be due to her addicted to that.
I do think maybe wearing right now
it was actually a place in oh wow.
Or a member and there was
a place back in Boston,
um,
when I body by design,
I believe it was called,
it might be,
I might have made it the wrong name.
I think it was babied by design though.
Um,
that might be totally wrong though.
Don't sue me on us.
But it was a,
um,
a place where all you did
was go and get zapped.
You go there and lay down and they would
cover you with these electrodes and
they would give you a body by design.
Like that was the idea,
you know,
and I they couldn't have
possibly are you sure?
But that's,
and that work,
there would be no 24 hour
fitness or la fitness.
I want to make the cheap version of
that with the plastic Chinese parts.
And you would just do it wast
just be break up in the morning.
I'll swole.
But Bruce Lee was into that shit too.
It's like,
I think it's,
you know,
people tend to buy these machines that
you stand on and he's cleaned that
Russian cosmonauts he was done and it
just shakes you and the clean up makes you
and shame.
Oh,
Ryan doesn't make any in shape.
No,
it doesn't get you in shape.
It stimulates your glands.
There's really the Russian cosmonauts
wherever those stand space.
We'll talk about it.
I'm going to try it.
All right.
Kevin Pereira.
Oh,
podcast pitches that everybody
know what's up bitches.
I don't think so.
I used to be,
I used to be fat.
I got and then I got crazy
the other end of spectrum.
Okay,
do this.
Just this
35 pounds.
That's like,
but and using your whole body,
you do two things.
One,
you made your body work as a unit.
What'd you don't do?
Just like,
I don't agree with any of that
stuff that's very isolating stuff.
No bench,
no curls,
no tricep extension.
I think all that stuff is bad for you.
Yeah.
I think it gives you an imbalance.
I think the best one you use your body,
it's used at all as one unit.
Yeah,
it probably is though.
Like my,
with my knee issues,
that's going to limit what
exercise blew it out to the slots,
you know,
click.
So I'm not spending all this stuff,
but you know he's doing,
yeah,
he does.
But he knows what he's
doing for him and he's a,
he's a monster.
I'm a ton of time.
It should be 35 pounds.
His playing weight.
Is it right to count bass by
tapping your penis and other for it?
I feel like that's something
that he's just doing.
This is not going to let you cheat.
You didn't do a little newbie.
Again,
like same thing.
It's still like this clean
hold it there like that.
Yeah.
Press it up big time.
And this is one 35 times in east side
sheep decree and keep your back nice and
straight and go deep.
Hold it down,
hold it.
Delays.
I'll play dungeon rate on a stair master.
[inaudible] my out.
Well it was a scared as well.
Do you remember were there in Phoenix
where there's a video game and you could
play like a boss again?
No,
it was tanks.
We've got an elliptical machine or I'll
come back from Atari that combat with
that
too much.
Well that's the neat,
it's like what is wrong?
Your name?
Great question.
I got to go see somebody about it.
How long ago did it happen?
December.
December?
Yeah.
Do you remember what happened?
Um,
I've always had issues with
that was a rollerblader drummer.
Constantly Bang on it.
So
I'll feel a shipped and then it's just
pain in the area now it feels like when
I,
when I actually moved as it as a
distinct click and in his pants,
that sounds a little bit
like stability thing.
You might just be a giant profit podcast.
Kevin prayer.
Ladies,
gentleman kept cars and the
house got some flashlight.
The Best Goodie bag.
This is the non gender flood lights
and he could contend dude holds a whole
bowl.
One of the world's my oyster.
It can be your kid's room not there.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
That was awesome.
I mean there's all a lot of
fucking debris out at sea.
Findlaw car was on the podcast today.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I found out Friday.
Loves fishing and loves to play it.
Cool.
Two things near and dear to my heart.
Missing jobs
plus was a lot of pressure.
Okay.
All
right.
Very difficult game.
10 balls.
Cognizanti to Joe Gold made me Joe goals.
Can you tell a difference
between pool sticks?
Yeah,
sure.
Huge difference.
I have a bunch of different cues made
by a bunch of like really high end pool
king makers.
Like the only thing that
I collect is pool cues.
The two ball.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh No.
Aw Shit like that.
Hmm.
Crap.
Only a house of rogue and where you see
monsters and mixed with Fisher price.
Wow.
I just got embarrassed.
Just the game side.
I don't know if I even hit a ball.
We haven't warmed up yet.
Fats,
just school.
It's not feminist.
Started there as he
plays like he is.
Well,
playing games,
playing games in the future,
you're risking,
you're risking your
future talking nonsense.
Yeah.
Dave,
you from this,
we're talking about race,
talking about
[inaudible],
disrespect,
ugly hells angels.
[inaudible].